thanks mike yes so
um as as you've heard us speak many
times before we're looking at these zero
epidemiology cities that are occurring
globally
um we are looking at a number of ways
first of which we're looking at the
publications that are coming out
these are peer-reviewed publications
pre-prints government reports
and today there's more than 150
published
results from such studies that mike has
just referred to
these are done various ways using
various methodologies some are looking
at populations some are looking at
stored uh clinical samples from people
who have shown up in hospitals
some are from blood donors and other
studies are done in specific types of
populations
among health workers for example um in
specific
areas where there was high transmission
in slums or in some
cities and towns where there was really
intense outbreaks
and the results uh indicate across all
of these 150 studies that
as mike has said that the vast majority
are below 10
with the exception of some high
incidence areas that are above 20 25
and some even higher and so the point is
that
these studies continue to tell us that
the vast majority of the world's
population remains susceptible
the way in which we're trying to get a
more standardized approach
to look at studies and be able to pull
these results
and combine these results if you will is
through what we call the unity studies
and this is a series of six protocols
that who has developed
with many many partners and in fact over
the last 11 years
because this work began with influenza
because we knew the importance
of really trying to understand the
extent of infection
as measured through these zero
epidemiology studies and the need to
standardize
this approach use the same approach
across multiple countries
so that we can better compare what is
happening in one country
and another and so who with our partners
has developed six uh protocol templates
um for different types of populations
and we're working with more than 50
countries right now
um to implement these studies where we
are providing technical support on the
adaptation of the protocol for the local
context
we're providing support and working with
the countries who are running these
studies themselves
um to carry them out and many of these
are underway
with the use of a standardized protocol
what we can do
when these results are finished and with
the permission of the
principal investigators of those is to
be able to compare those and pull those
and this will help us get a good global
estimate of what is happening
in different populations you also
mentioned the
infection fatality ratio so in addition
to this there are a number of
statistical groups mathematical modeling
groups that are looking at
the infection fatality ratio which is
the number of deaths
over the number of divided by the number
of estimated
infections and there are several papers
that have come
out that are looking at this um
several of these analyses have used
published or pre-print ciro
epidemiologic study results
and they all converge uh around a point
estimate of around
0.6 now that may not sound like a lot
but that is a lot higher than influenza
and the infection fatality ratio
increases dramatically with aids
so we can provide you with these papers
these papers are published
but there is a big increase in the
infection fatality ratio by age
but overall these converge around
thank you i would like now to invite um
bloomberg reporter for the next question
tim
loth from bloomberg can you hear me tim
yes and can you hear me yes very well go
ahead please
all right thank you yeah so my question
has to do with the recent upsurge in
europe
right now um even in countries like
spain
uh where the current wave infections is
hitting especially hard
hospitalizations due to the virus are
still far
lower than they were at the peak of the
first wave
um i'm just looking for an update on
your current thinking as to why this is
and what risk factors might cause this
trend to
worsen in the coming weeks
thank you tim dr ryan maria will
uh
clearly as we've seen in in all cases of
rising incidents so far
this pandemic that the incidence of
hospitalization and deaths
lags behind the incidence of cases
themselves and it takes a number of
weeks usually for those numbers to feed
through into the system
but uh i do uh also we also recognize
that within that
that like has been over a longer period
of time
and it may reflect a shift in the age
distribution of cases or at least of
tested cases
with more disease in younger age groups
who don't tend to be
hospitalized or don't tend to have fatal
outcomes that certainly
certainly a factor but what we are
beginning to see worryingly in places
like france like
the uk ireland and other countries is
hospitalization rates increasing
ic occupant icu occupancy rising
and it's really important that health
systems are able to cope
with what will be an increasing number
of cases in hospital and icus over the
coming weeks
the question remains as to
how many of those daily incident cases
convert into hospitalizations and then
into very seriously ill patients
and we don't know that we don't know
that for sure um
if this trend continues yes it could be
done to the age base
in terms of people going into icu or
even being hospitalized again maria may
speak to this but
we've learned a lot about how to
recognize early symptoms of the disease
how to ensure the patients who are
vulnerable are better protected
and those that are vulnerable get access
to early treatment
i think a lot of this is making sure
that those people most likely
to fare badly are in a clinical pathway
that gets them into intensive care or
supported care
much more quickly we also back in march
in april
people on hospital trolleys great
difficulties in triaging patients
patients who probably needed immediate
care not getting immediate
care and therefore the streamlining
and efficiency of the system is very
very important that efficiency drops
as the system comes under pressure and
it's a great testament
to the emergency particularly people
working in emergency rooms
in the front end of our systems have
really
improved the way in which we streamline
the clinical pathways
in the hospital to ensure that the
sickest patients are those most likely
to become sicker are getting access to
care quickly
we then add in the advent of
therapeutics like dexamethasone
and the use of high flow oxygen
oxygen concentrator so many other things
that have come on stream
so i think overall clinical care is
improving which won't reduce
hospitalization rate per se
but certainly will reduce death rates so
a number of factors
in that it may also be uh and this is
something that remains to be explored
uh whether or not the very fact that
people have been more socially distanced
the very fact that people are taking
more care with hygiene
whether or not people are being exposed
to a lower infectious dose
and that is something that's still very
very speculative
something that will be explored and is
being explored as we speak but the
reality is that
we may not be perfectly effective at
reducing transmission between people
but there is a link between the
infectious dose the amount of virus
you're exposed to
and the severity of your illness or your
likelihood
to become sick again a lot of work going
on in that and i believe in the end it
will turn out to be multifactorial
there have been many reasons but i think
we need to be really careful right now
not to make an assumption
that the current disconnect between the
rising number of cases
and deaths that could reconnect very
very badly and very catastrophically
unless we're very very careful
thanks so much i mean i think you
described it perfectly
as you said it's a combination of
factors that we're seeing this
happening across europe and in fact a
number of countries where we're seeing
a lower mortality rate compared to the
beginning of this pandemic
and part of it is due to surveillance
because we are able to
test more we are able to expand our
surveillance
beyond just severe patients beyond just
individuals who show up at healthcare
and this is a hallmark of outbreaks and
pandemics in the beginning
you tend to focus on those severe
patients because that is what your
system is
and so as surveillance expands uh we are
able to test
more we are able to do contact tracing
uh we tend to find
more individuals who are on the more
mild end of the spectrum
um so that's one second um through these
second peaks
that we are seeing in a number of
countries there is an
age shift in the average age of cases
that we are detecting
and part of that is because as societies
are opening up
individuals are coming away from those
stay-at-home measures
they're going back to work um there's a
lot of socializing that is
that is happening i mean unfortunately
in some of those situations
the virus really really likes this type
of
setting it can spread and we
have seen quite a few outbreaks in a
number of countries across
entertainment type settings across
religious settings across sporting
events
and that will drive the age down and we
know that younger individuals
tend to have less underlying conditions
and they don't develop as
much severe disease as someone who is
older
um but also we are getting better at
preventing
um outbreaks happening in vulnerable
populations
the long-term living facilities for
example in some countries
were incredibly devastating in the
beginning and unfortunately there still
happened in some countries
but if we could prevent the virus from
entering a long-term living facility for
example
we could prevent amplification
but the other side of this point is that
we are getting much better at dealing
with patients
clinicians nurses front line workers
have experience with coping 19 now
so earlier testing means earlier access
to clinical care
it means checking that oxygen level and
that individual quicker
it means providing oxygen quicker when
needed
it means providing ventilatory support
if necessary providing dexamethasone for
people who are severe and who are
critical
and all of that saves lives so we're
getting much better at
actually dealing with patients and
treating patients and caring for them
which are leading to more positive
outcomes but the one thing we worry
about
and i know we've said this many times
one of the things that we worry about
a mild infection a mild disease we are
only now starting to really learn of the
long-term impacts on the heart
on the brain on the lungs on mental
health
on people's ability to recover from
covet
infection and so not only do we need to
work very hard at reducing mortality and
we are seeing the benefits
of that we still need to reduce the
numbers of infections that we are seeing
and again we come back to all of the
tools that are in place to be able to do
this
we can do it all we can do this all
together because we are all in this
together
and it's about individual measures that
we take to protect ourselves
and having the enabled environment for
us to take those to protect ourselves
and our loved ones
thank you um i would like now to invite
uh a reporter from
the independent no i think
he uh we will come back to borzo from
the independent later on
if he's still online i would like now to
invite stephanie
from reuters stephanie can you hear me
yes thank you for taking our question um
i wondered uh whether um as you as you
probably know australia
researchers today said in a study that
was published earlier today that the
stars covered two virus can survive on
banknotes and glass and stainless steel
for up to 28 days
which is of course quite a bit longer
than the flu virus
so what can wh o say about the
transmissibility from such surfaces
please
over over such long periods of time and
and do you have any
um you know increased concerns or new
advice
following this study that was published
today thank you
thank you stephanie i would like to
invite dr uh von karkov to take this
question
off the floor thanks fidel thanks
stephanie for this question yes we're
aware of the study that was
um published this was an experimental
study that was looking at the cyrus cov2
virus
it looked at samples that had very high
viral loads
there are other studies that have been
done under experimental conditions and
of course we look at those studies to
look at our advice and look at how we
make recommendations for disinfectants
and what the study found
it was done under experimental
conditions so not real world conditions
um it was done in the dark which means
it didn't have any uv
light of what you would see um in under
normal real world type situations
um and it found that the virus could
remain viable for 28 days at 20 degrees
celsius
and 24 hours at 40 degrees celsius and
it looked at different types of surfaces
like glass and stainless steel
and paper and polymer banknotes and so
we use this information um to look at
our disinfectants the good news is that
this virus can be disinfected uh with
with disinfectants with chlorine with
different types of
very very quickly um and we know that
full mites or or
touching of contaminated surface is one
of the ways this virus can
transmit and so what we worry about is
if someone is infected and they release
the virus and it falls onto a surface
uh if it isn't disinfected and someone
touches that surface
they don't wash their hands or use
alcohol-based rub
um if they touch their eyes or their
nose or their mouth they can infect
themselves that way
so we continue to recommend these basics
we continue to recommend
that there's environmental cleaning that
is happening in
areas where there's known patients of
course in hospitals
homes where people are being cared for
but also making sure that we disinfect
surfaces
and again there's good news that
disinfectants like bleach work
very well at uh removing the virus
and they're very highly effective of
killing this virus so
the the measures remain in place hand
hygiene
carry your alcohol paste rub make sure
that you use it
the very basis of hand hygiene and go
back to the old social water argument as
well
soap and water is probably one of the
most effective public health
interventions that's ever been
invented because it does everything from
getting rid of all kinds of bacteria
all kinds of viruses on your hands and
prevents the spread of
any number of diseases from from cholera
to
to coronaviruses so
i think the having access to soap and
water
having access to hand sanitizer and
coming back to those basic messages that
we've been speaking about
for four months since the very beginning
about hand hygiene and not to forget
hand hygiene and i've seen this myself
and personally witnessed it
and i'm very very pleased to see the
adherence to masks and to physical
distancing and then i've witnessed many
times
people have access to hand hygiene
stations going in and out of shops
or public transport and they don't tend
to use it because they've made an
association
that in some way this disease is only
spread through a droplets or only
spread to another means and in fact this
disease can be spread through
contamination of surfaces
however long those surfaces are
contaminated for so it's very very
important
that we continue and again dg has spoken
about this many times
do it all and that includes hand hygiene
that includes washing your hands
regularly as regularly as you can not so
easy for many people in the world who
don't have access even to soap
and water to be able to do that and that
is a huge injustice
in the world not only for the case of
coronavirus but for so many
other diseases so i would just say to
everybody
hand hygiene is a major part of
coronavirus control
this study only reinforces that we'll
see
as maria says in the long term what the
the implications of this and other
studies are
but the message is wash your hands often
with soap and water or use de-sanitizer
or sanitizer
thank you very much i would like now to
invite
sophie from sabc south africa
broadcasting company sophie can you hear
me
yes i can hear you my question is
directed
to dr ryan and dr tedros we have
a situation where most countries are
currently
going through elections for example on
the continent
you have ivor coast you have tanzania in
two weeks time
you also have the united states of
america and there you look at what
leaders are doing in terms of their
rallies and their campaigns
you have these large numbers are you not
worried that this will lead
elections do many things
they're an essential part of our lives
and they're absolutely central
to how many societies live survive and
thrive they're very important parts
of the cycle of life however they do
tend to bring people together
we've seen many examples over the last
nine months where elections have
actually been held
very safely and with appropriate
measures and have
been been straightforward enough to
manage
and implement it takes effort we've
worked very closely
in the past in the same way we've done
for all types of mass gatherings and
we've worked on a risk management
approach you cannot reduce the risk to
zero but what you can do is identify and
manage those risks especially
where in-person voting is the choice of
the country
we don't specify to any country what the
proper choice is for the type of
election they need to run
that is based on their own risk
assessment but we do offer them advice
on how to reduce those risks
if in-person elections are the way
forward and in fact we're working right
now
finalizing specific guidance for
countries who choose in-person elections
learning from the last eight nine months
as to what has worked in those
circumstances and we'll be issuing that
guidance
in the coming days uh it's a very
important
question but like any form of gathering
any form of social
process at society level it is possible
to manage them and reduce risk to an
absolute minimum
if everybody participates and if
everybody adheres to
what is an agreed method and agreed
practice
the problem very often is when those
practices are ignored
and that's that's essentially something
that can't be
legislated for but it is possible to
hold safe
elections uh if the proper measures are
put in place
thank you dr ryan i would like now to
invite
simon ateba africa news today to ask the
next
question simon can you hear me
yes i can hear you thank you for taking
my question this time on october from
today news africa in washington dc
i know it's really hard for who to talk
about specific members especially the us
and especially
president trump and especially 22 days
to an election
but on thursday last week he
11 days ago he tested positive for
corona virus and he's gone back
on the campaign trail i was wondering
first
how long is according to who guideline
how long does the how long does the
virus stay in the system
when does he know there is no more a
risk to other people especially because
he has not done
a second test that has proven that he's
tested negative
and the i was also wondering if was the
best way to go back on the campaign
trail after testing positive for
coronavirus
thank you
that's a lot of questions certainly not
the
personal positions to anyone in the
world and would not like to make a
comment on specific
individuals what we can say
is that the u.s public health services
have
very clear criteria in place for what
represents
uh the release of an individual from
what might be isolation due to being
infected and the criteria in the us
maria may outline them are very clear
from wh perspective
we allow both testing and duration of
a number of days since the onset of
symptoms
both approaches are used by who are
offered to our member states as
mechanisms
i believe maria it's ten days from the
onset of symptoms and plus
three days from the onset of the last or
the cessation of the last symptoms
and again all countries have adapted
that according to their national
protocols
and therefore we would not we wouldn't
comment on whether
any specific individual meets the
requirements of their national protocol
thanks yes so um i can tell you yes
exactly what mike has said um for
symptomatic individuals it's
it's ten days from the time of september
plus the three days of symptom
resolution meaning no fever no
respiratory symptoms we also have
criteria for asymptomatic individuals
um but what we what we do is we work
with countries all over the world we
work with labs all over the world to
look at when people
uh test positive using pcr testing we're
also looking at virus
isolation from those individuals and
there are a handful of studies that have
been
underway we've outlined our
understanding
of the science in a scientific brief on
this
which is on our website and we are
continuing to work with labs um
who are following patients and
individuals over time um
and so this is a body of work that is
very important for us we work with
our counterparts in the us as well thank
you so much
i would like now to invite um
byram from anatolu news agency
for the next question byram can you hear
me
yes i can leave you thank you father for
taking my question and
good evening to everybody that i saw for
work
on a good news from double ho about the
community vaccine
from who perspective where do we stand
with the vaccine development
as number of countries says they are on
the cusp of having
successful vaccine like china russia usa
uk
uk and today turkey so when will we get
a safe and effective vaccine at the
earliest
what is your latest update on this do
you have any quick news for us today
thank you
thank you i would like to invite dr
swaminathan
to answer this question yes thank you
for that question and we
of course continue to track the
development of vaccines and it's really
very encouraging
to see the progress in the clinical
trials
happening all around the world as you
know we have about 40
vaccine candidates now in some stage of
clinical trials and ten of them
are in the phase three trials which are
the late the
late stage uh clinical trials which will
tell us about both the efficacy
and the safety so the best that we could
we could make a guess or predict looking
at when a trial started
and when it is likely to have enough
data to submit to
the regulators is the earliest is
starting from december of 2020 into the
early part of 2021
we expect a number of clinical trials to
start providing data
for regulators to look at and this is
going to be a lot of data for regulators
and and also the who
we also put out a call for expressions
of interest from vaccine developers
to submit whatever data they have to us
and so have a rolling submission
and update us but unless we see results
from phase three
trials so as i said the majority of the
ones which are currently
in phase three trials will be reporting
in the early part of 2021
and beyond it will continue because many
others are going to enter into phase
three over the next few months
so the good thing is we'll have a number
of different vaccine trial results that
we will be looking at
over a period of the next i think six to
12 months
and and then both regulatory agencies
and the who
will have to make decisions on
either emergency use authorization or on
regular
licensing of the vaccines depending on
on the data set that they're able to
provide so i think in the first quarter
of
uh 2021 is when we are going to see most
of the data coming in
thank you dr swaminathan i think dr
i think there are there are other issues
that will come
into play as well you know dr sumiya dr
swaminathan referred to the
the regulator's part once you finalize
a phase three trial you
this vaccine will need to be licensed if
it
proves positive go safe on the safety
side and
on the efficacy site this vaccine will
have to be licensed
in the country where it's been
experimented where the trial took
place and we also have the
the manufacturing capacity it will need
to be
available
to be used at country level so there are
many many steps that need to be taken
after it's uh the the phase three trial
actually ends the wgo is working very
closely with the national regulatory
authorities and
like dr suminata referred to we issued
an expression of interest for the
emergency use listing of a vaccine and
we are accepting
any producer any candidate vaccine
that's in phase
2b or phase 3 and we expect
this will help to move the process
faster as we get to those years and we
we start to analyze
not only the efficacy and safety but we
work at the same time with a good
manufacturing
capacity at each of these these vaccine
producers
right so that when the the vaccine is
finally
concluded the trials you we do have a
clear vision of the the quality
assurance of the product that will come
to the market
so
thank you very much for taking my
question um
i would like to know about the forecast
in mexico
the first wave is not over yet the cases
are still on the rise
the tests are done there are more than
80 000
deaths but it's possible that there are
three times more death
so mexico is one of the of those 10
countries that dr
dr theros just mentioned so
i would like to to know what
recommendations do you have and
there is also another serious problem
because about
1 000 1 000 children with
cancer have died due to the lack of
treatment
a problem that began to appear in public
hospitals before the pandemic
so that is a the situation i would like
to know what is your
recommendation
the situation in mexico obviously
remains uh
difficult until october the 10th there
were
over 814 thousand cases and
uh over 83 600 that's from code
again i think putting it in context i
think uh half
nearly half of all the confirmed cases
have come from mexico city
and and the state of mexico
and sonora so they in
in that sense there's been a big impact
in certain areas
a quarter of the patients reported to us
have required
hospitalizations and was going to
preponderance of male
females but uh 52
to 48 but not such a great uh
preponderance
again many people like we've seen all
over the world have had
underlying conditions including
hypertension diabetes obesity
we're the main associated conditions
there
and you know mexico has been running
this
traffic light system uh three-level
traffic light system and interestingly
many other countries have adapted
adopted similar traffic light systems
and the last time
was mexico was one of the first
countries in the americas to
introduce that traffic light system and
we would
uh support mexico and continuing to do
that
health personnel have been very much
affected in mexico
and again predominantly 60 reported in
in females which probably represents the
fact that
health workers in mexico are
predominantly female themselves
48 48 of the cases and nurses about a
quarter of the cases
in doctors and another corporate and
other health professionals in mexico
and clearly uh protecting those health
workers is very important
we have our power office have uh
obviously continued to recommend mexico
to continue the training protection
provision of equipment
to frontline health workers in mexico
the again the same issues arise in terms
of
a shift of disease into younger
populations there have been issues
in the past and the testing strategy and
the amount of testing done
we'd also like to come in mexico it's
been very careful to try it's had
a large bump in cases over the weekend
just before the weekend
because it's actually changed a lot of
its definition of cases not
to reduce the number of cases but to
actually capture more cases
particularly those who weren't tested so
mexico now
considers cases who are
epidemiologically associated with the
confirmed case
to be cases and the same with debts it
actually
puts mexico in a situation where it will
tend to report
more cases than elsewhere and it is to
be commended for its uh
transparency uh on that so i would say
yes and no more than any many other
countries in in north central and south
america
no countries out of the world mexico
continues to be in difficulty and it is
very tragic to hear
your reporting on cancer patients and
we've seen
this impact around the world on oncology
services around the world
outpatient services and others for
essential care
in many ways and i think the dg has said
this many times before
covert to an extent has caused some of
these problems but it's also revealed
huge inequities in the system as you
said many of these issues may have been
present
before so mexico no more than every
country in the world
has serious inequities in the way
healthcare is delivered
and the way healthcare is paid for and
it is a tragic to hear in any country
that children
would die unnecessarily from treatable
cancers
thank you dr ryan we are up to the hour
now
i would like to invite dr tederos for
final comments
over to you yeah thank you no thank you
thanks
fedilla and thanks also to all who have
joined today
and see you in our next presser thank
you
thank you dr tedros just reminding
journalists that we will be sending
the the audiophile and dr teder's
remarks
right after the press conference the
full transcript
will be posted on the ww2 website
tomorrow morning
sorry for journalist i wasn't able to
take questions from
for time constraints don't hesitate to
contact
us thank you so much and see you soon
you